hey gang welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Sam Bash and let's talk about that
mind-blowing episode of the flash last
night literally mind-blowing look at
this bad episode of 407 therefore I am
oh boy we got a solid idea of just how
scary white people can be can't wait to
see the thinker in future episodes but
I'm getting off-topic let's talk about
the big Easter eggs and the most
delightful comic book references from
this episode here's the quick spoiler
warning for the flash TV show past
present future episodes comics movies
etc let's get going starting at the top
of this episode with number 10 the
thinking cap if you wouldn't mind
throwing up a clip of a thinker with
that magical cap will you please kind
added her bad boy is the classic
throwback to the original thinker which
is still Clifford to vote but before he
got his noggin scooped off picture again
thank you so much unlike the show's
version of the thinking cap which can
just boost Cliff's intellect the
original cap could control people's
minds and give the where some form of
telekinesis good these powers show up on
the flash possibly hmm what else could
that float and chair do I wonder I got
some hints later in the episode but uh
stay tuned speaking of the thinker and
his chair number 9 on the list is a
quick rundown of all the connections
this episode had to season one
specifically the pilot but here we go
I know we all miss the magic that was
the first season of the show and the
writers wanted to remind you that they
heard you and they're doing their best
alright they're trying take you for
example
right off the bat our main villain is in
a wheelchair due to the particle
accelerator explosion much like Harrison
wells in season 1 how he used a
wheelchair as a way to seem
non-threatening you know like to kind of
get people to stop looking at maybe
don't look at my evil stuff I'm doing
you know I mean we even see the original
Harrison wells from season 1 oh boy do I
miss just how creepy he was there's a
special type of creepy that's hard to do
kids another throwback is the rain
floating up much like in season 1
whenever the reverse-flash would show up
or when dark matter was present liquids
in rooms would start to float up oh so
cool and much like the reverse-flash in
season one the thinker has been secretly
spying on team flash both through the
samurai helmet and through hidden
cameras in his own home catching barry
doing some B&E Breaking and Entering
bacon and eggs my favorite food and
finally we see the return of the classic
board of clues and Barry's office where
he's investigating to vote much like he
created in season 1 the one that you
know the board have had all the hints to
who killed his mom he did
No you know what this got me thinking I
got to rewatch the first season cuz I
miss season one there I missed season
one flash moving on to number eight on
the list check out this sick shout-out
to the MCU my spidey sense is tingling
boy off the charts ooh baby that
reference is obviously referring to
Marvel's spider-man's trademark ability
to spider sense the wall callers six
this usually helps Peter Parker sense
danger when it's near which makes sense
in this scene since Barry's getting a
weird vibe from DeVoe love these Marvel
shoutouts first The Incredible Hulk and
now Spidey
I'm guessing Marvel Comics might exist
in this universe could be cool you know
what else is cool famous unsolved
mathematical questions yes yay this is
number 7 on our list listen to all the
mathematical tidbits that come flying
out of the thinker's mouth Oh what
Riemann hypothesis Gilberts fifties
problem Ryman's hypothesis and Hilbert's
15th question actually comes from a list
of 23 which over half have been claimed
to be solved up until now a 15th is
still up in the air we don't know if
it's been solved yet but thanks thinker
again this is all according to the
internet because I am NOT a
mathematician at all I literally have no
idea what any of this means if you do
though throw down an explanation in the
comment section explain it like I'm 5
next up on to number 6 on this list
sticking with the scene of the thinker
being a know-it-all he mentions a famous
mysterious murderer who was ejected I
only bring this up because this actually
ties back to another DC CW show yay 2
weeks back the legends of tomorrow
thought they were tracking down Jack the
Ripper but of course it turned out to be
a vampire but actually faked out turned
out to be an evil time-traveling
recently resurrected magical
supervillain classic number 5 and meliss
brings us back to the thinker whose
origin I really enjoyed in this episode
when the thinker mentions what is
happening to his body my mind is drawing
energy for my body I immediately felt
like this was a throwback to one of DC's
most famous villains who actually has
already been on the big screen who is it
remember way back when during the Green
Lantern film Peter Sarsgaard played the
one and only Hector Hammond me neither
ya know that movie's painful to watch
but fun fact about Hector Hammond in the
comics his brain starts to become more
and more powerful making his
intelligence skyrocket and grant some
supernatural abilities but unfortunately
this gift takes away his mobility and
eventually his ability to speak don't
worry he's got telepathy he doesn't
this definitely feels like there's a
connection between these two brainy
villains but let me know what you guys
think
next up with number four let's know what
captain Singh says during this scene
with Barry and the mechanic use your
time away to consider your future in law
enforcement other jobs well I know
there's probably numerous in the comics
even one time in the new 52 when he was
a bartender for a second but I actually
think this is an odd that recently
released Justice League film which I
have very much enjoyed our cinematic
Barry Allen is a busy bee not at the
CCPD crime lab however three other jobs
could they be by the way if they do do a
flashpoint movie I really hope we get a
glimpse of Grant Gustin in the
timestream somewhere come on to that
leather suit in there please number
three here's a fun music cue that
perfectly describes Barry's attitude
during this episode here in spirit some
of the words go like this no compromise
but willing to sacrifice believe what
you want sure Barry did go little over
the top when he was investigating two
VOC I broke into his house but if we
know Barry he sometimes never
compromises until the end of the episode
when he softens up a little bit changes
its tune actually this song could apply
to most superheroes but let's not get
into that just a second cuz we've got a
big easter egg that should have been
mentioned earlier but I was waiting for
the right time alright let's talk about
the thinker's chair let's take a look
sure this chairs been in many episodes
before this one flying around shooting
stuff helping him think classic and I
had a feeling of what this chair was
inspired to look like and many of you
guys have pointed this out but I think
we can finally say this chair feels an
awful lot like the new God met Ron's
chair met Ron's chair or the möbius
chair is very much the same design wise
as the thinkers floating chair on the
show it even plugs in to the person
sitting on the chair allowing them to
access unlimited information the comic
version of the chair isn't so literal
though with the whole plugging in the
only difference here is that the comic
book version can teleport and time
travel sometimes who knows maybe we'll
see that happen in future episodes maybe
this is a weird season after all don't
worry it keeps getting weirder than that
brings us to number one on the list
one of the biggest Easter eggs ever that
team flash just kind of throws away like
it's nothing this is huge listen to what
Wally says when he finally returns
self-reflection
the battle with a starfish from out of
space if you respect a starfish from
outer space it's not nothing
Wally just confirmed that star au is in
the air over star au is this gigantic
alien starfish they can control people's
minds supposed to take over the world
you know classic and the flesh has gone
up against ro many times in the comics
fun facts taro has already appeared on
another DC TV show remember the pilot
for NBC's powerless me neither but if
you look right here your star au is
climbing a build and then he goes so
cool and lastly here are a few honorable
mentions I just wanted to point out that
when Barry puts on the hoodie he becomes
Hoodie Allen and secondly the Japanese
phrase that the thinker uses translates
to yes I only use it during slash for
academic conferences boo boring I want
about the translate to something
nefarious shoutout to reina scully for
helping me translate that anyway though
thank you guys so much for checking out
this video let me know what you think in
the comments down below what do you
think enlightenment could be do you
think that the thinker is planning on
using the Speed Force to help extend his
life maybe let us know your theories
down below be sure to like this video
share with your friends and subscribe to
new rock stars for more breakdown so
we've got a bunch in the channel you're
missing out if you're not watching every
single one of them make sure you hit me
up on Twitter if you have more questions
at Sam basher that's my handle I'll see
you guys next time